Une bière, un café pour la une ! Oh ! Oh !
Oups ! Pardon, désolé pour le café
mais je vous rassure, ce n'est pas une question d'agilité,
c'est juste une question ... de mousse.
L'abus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé, consommez avec modération.
Si la mousse colle aux lèvres et...
à la moustache
elle colle aussi au verre et c'est ça qui
empêche le liquide de déborder.
Ce sont deux physiciens français qui en
apportent la preuve en images.
Là, on voit un liquide sans mousse.
Et là, avec sa petite mousse protectrice.
Et vous pouvez même faire l'expérience
chez vous à la maison.
Amateurs de bière, comme de café,
mais aussi forts en maths,
nos chercheurs ont réussi à trouver
les équations physiques qui décrivent ce phénomène.
Cela leur a permis de montrer que les bulles
en se frottant contre la paroi
dissipent l'énergie du mouvement.
Bref ! Plus il y a de bulles, moins ça tangue.
Mais attention, pas la peine non plus de trop en rajouter.
Dans leurs tasses rectangulaires,
très chics au demeurant,
les chercheurs ont montré que
cinq couches de bulles suffisaient
à réduire le débordement d'un facteur 10.
Bon, j'entends déjà celles et ceux qui vont dire
que la science pourrait servir à
des choses plus utiles que
la mousse de la bière ou du café.
Et bien sachez que la maîtrise de la mousse
pourrait permettre de sécuriser des transports de matières dangereuses
comme le gaz liquide ou le carburant de fusée.
En ajoutant une petite couche protectrice
sur ces liquides sensibles aux chocs
on pourrait éviter la catastrophe.
Et bien voilà un petit Zeste de Science
à raconter en soirée,
si vous voulez vous faire... mousser !
Et voilà... Abonne-toi !